joining us now dr. deborah birx of the
white house coronavirus task force dr.
welcome back to Fox News Sunday thank
you
a month ago you and President Trump were
both talking about a total of 60,000
kovat 19 doubts take a look it looks
like we'll be at about a sixty thousand
mark which is 40,000 less than the
lowest number thought of look at how
much the model has changed in just a
week remember just a week ago it was
80,000 now it's 60,000 early this coming
week we're gonna reach a hundred
thousand deaths from the corona virus
and those models that you're a sighting
and now talk about close to a hundred
and fifty thousand deaths by August what
happened doctor I think a few things are
together so from the beginning and I
think when we had that first briefing we
talked about 1.2 million to 2.4 million
and a hundred thousand to two 240,000
people succumbing to this incredibly
aggressive virus those are the figures
that we continue to stay on by in this
first wave and really understanding how
to prevent future hospitalizations and
future deaths is really what we're
focused on every single day but to press
it a little bit a month ago you were
saying we're going to come down below
the low end of the model which is a
hundred to two hundred 40,000 to 60,000
so my guess my question is in this last
month did you underestimate the strength
of the virus did we reopen too soon did
we reopen without sufficient
restrictions what I was saying in that
briefing that you were talking about is
what that current model was showing
there are different models we have been
using all along and really trying to
learn primarily not just for models but
understanding what has happened in Spain
and Italy
and the UK and really tracking those
numbers we understand that our mortality
rates are less than those three
countries and that's really due to the
incredible work of our frontline
hospital workers but we understand that
these number of infections has led to
this level of mortality and our job now
going forward is to do everything we can
to prevent additional hospitalizations
and additional mortality well let me let
me pick up on that doctor because this
is as we said Memorial Day weekend and
people are going out more in public a
lot of them are going to beaches
we're running video here some people are
social distancing but the picture is you
probably can't see on the screen right
now in Venice Beach California big
crowds of people some of them close
together not wearing masks how concerned
are you by some of what you're saying
around the country this Memorial Day
weekend well you know last time we spoke
I was concerned about people coming
together without mass even during the
protest and now I'm very concerned when
people go out and don't maintain social
distancing what do we know that has
changed
we now have excellent scientific
evidence of how far droplets go when we
speak or just simply talking to one
another and we know that it's important
for people to socially interact but we
also know it's important that we have to
have masks on if we're less than six
feet and that we have to maintain that
six feet different different distance we
know being outside does help we know son
does help in killing the virus but that
doesn't change the fact that people need
to be responsible and maintain that
distance we know you're talking to the
governor from Arkansas he's made it
clear that there are super spreader
events when people come together because
of the nature of this virus and because
of a symptomatic spread and people
aren't intentionally spreading the virus
they don't know they're infected but
they come together and they're under
that six feet and everybody who gets
exposed to that person less than six
feet has a chance of becoming infected
so do you think some of the this crowd
of people at beaches this Memorial Day
weekend is that a super spreader event
well Friday when I discussed this during
the press briefing I was really hoping
to convey that very clear message to the
American people we want you to be
outside we know that there are ways that
you can even play tennis with mark balls
so you're not touching each other's
balls we know there's a way for you to
go out and play golf and spade distance
to hike to be outside in nature to be at
the beach but really within that is the
absolute requirement because across the
country we know that there is still
virus out there and we see what
workplaces are doing to make it safe we
see what nursing homes are doing to try
to make it safer for their residents
let's even in public make sure that
we're doing everything that we need to
do to make it safe for others in public
President Trump said on Friday that he
is now declaring that houses of worship
are providing essential services and he
wants governor's to open houses of
worship right away today take a look if
they don't do it I will override the
governor's in America we need more
prayer not less but as you know there
have been a few cases not widespread but
there have been a few cases one in
Arkansas some in California where people
some of the may symptomatic with kovat
19 go to houses of worship and spread
and there are more infections and in
some cases even death
is it safe to open all houses of worship
across the country today I think two
things happen on Friday the president
asks for the CDC to make sure there were
guidelines posted to make it clear of
how churches could open safely and
during then the press briefing I made it
clear that it's very important for
governors and communities to let people
know where there is still high levels of
virus like it is here in Washington DC
in Chicago and in
la and to really ensure that those with
vulnerabilities are protected so ill
although it may be safe for some to go
to churches and social distance it may
not be safe for those with pre-existing
conditions and that's why in phase one
and phase two we've asked for those
individuals with with vulnerabilities to
really ensure that they are protected
and sheltering in place while we open up
America then there are the issue of mass
which we touched on before and we are
seeing growing confrontations for
instance in stores where customers say
you gotta wear a mask and some customers
say you are violating my rights here's
an example of that I'm asking this
member to put on a mask because that is
our company policy
so either wear the mask and I'm not
doing it I woke up in a free country I'm
asking you a public-health question not
a legal question what would you tell
someone who says I have a right not to
wear a mask in public what we have said
to people is there's clear scientific
evidence now by all the droplet
experiments that happen and that others
have done to show that a mask does
prevent droplets from reaching others
and out of respect for each other as
Americans that care for each other we
need to be wearing masks in public when
we cannot social distance it's really
critically important we have the
scientific evidence of how important
mask wearing is to prevent those
droplets from reaching others do you
wish I understand it's a special case
ease everybody around him has been
tested and obviously he's on television
but both from a safety point of view and
from a public messaging point of view do
you wish the president wore a mask in
public well the President did wear a
mask while he was less than six feet in
a kit occasion where that was important
over I think when he was traveling last
last week I think he I taught with him
every day and every moment
I don't know if he can maintain social
distance I've asked everybody
independently to really make sure that
you're wearing a mask if you can't
maintain the six feet I'm assuming that
in majority of cases he's able to
maintain that six feet distance finally
there were some promising reports this
week about we might get a vaccine sooner
than we expected here's the President on
that this week we're looking - when I
say quickly we're looking to get it by
the end of the year if we can maybe
before we're doing tremendously well a
month ago you and dr. Falchi were both
talking about it taking 12 to 18 months
to get a mass to get a vaccine now
you're talking about possibly by the end
of the year which would cut that
timeline in half I understand everybody
wants it how likely is it that we're
gonna see a vaccine readily available by
the end of this year I think what would
make it potentially possible is what
we're what the president has asked
everyone to do in this public-private
partnership with funding directly to
make vaccine at risk and what do I mean
by that that means making vaccine before
we know it's full safety and it's full
effect in it what we call its efficacy
profile to make vaccine starting now as
quickly as possible
so when there is that efficacy and
safety signal so we're not sure cutting
the efficacy and safety testing what we
are short cutting is the normal
development tine of manufacturing and so
really starting manufacturing what would
be six months early or seven months
early that's how you can potentially
shorten this by four to six or even
eight months and so that's what's
happening now is taking the most
promising candidates and getting them
into manufacturing and shirring that you
can scale and produce these vaccines at
the level that is needed for Americans
well we all hope that happens you can be
sure dr. Burks thank you thanks for your
time this holiday weekend please come
back